hey guys this is a quick public service
announcement before my interview with
david horowitz you know david horowitz
actually said a couple lines that we are
being forced to censor because of the
youtube rules we have never done
something like this before and as far as
i know david horowitz is a free citizen
in the free country of the united states
who is entitled to free speech that
being said i can't risk having this
channel deleted from youtube and that
basically is what would happen if we
went ahead and aired it unedited so you
will hear some bleeps in this interview
if you would like to hear what david
horowitz a free man in a free country
actually said you can check out the full
video at
rubinreport.locals.com and quick shout
out to susan wojecki over at youtube
if you look at the
democrats agenda
it's not about getting rid of trump it's
not about winning an election it's about
establishing a one-party state
stacked the supreme court that's to
abolish the independent judiciary
abolish the electoral college which was
designed to force presidential
candidates to compete in battleground
states where they didn't have a majority
let's force them to compromise our whole
system
is built on compromise that that's why
we've only had one civil war and no uh
successful crew date hats
the democrat
program is a fascist program
there is no
nobody the only republicans who were
legitimate
are those
uh you know like liz jane right they
love they love liz cheney now because
she's a pet so so you you lay all of
this out in the book it's quite
extraordinary actually and as i said
you've been right about a lot of stuff
way before
a lot of people so what do you think the
average
conservative and i now use that term in
a broad sense if you believe america is
good
you're a conservative as far as i'm
concerned what do you think the average
conservative can do to fight this
because it feels like the deck is
completely stacked against us well
republican conservatives have been
asleep for 50 years while the democrats
have taken over our culture i wrote five
books on the universities that
one of them people paid a little
attention to but the republican i
organized academic freedom campaigns
and i got no real support out of the
republican
party
but a bomb between obama and
i call them the alzheimer puppet uh
i
one of the nastiest human beings on the
planet i don't know how he gets his
reputation for being a nice guy
um they've begun to wake people up and
donald trump has given
our country and and
patriots a great gift and that is he has
created the first mass conservative
movement in our history
when i came into the right in the
mid-80s
40 years ago now looked around and said
where's the ground army they're all my
ex-comrades on the left are in or they
had a hundred organizations or 200
to harass and threaten
and defame
politicians until they got on there
into their program and corporations
are corporations involved you know
corporations are basically cowards
they don't want to lose customers that's
their
bottom line
but if you harass them enough
um
they will respond and it's interesting
already the backlash has caused them uh
disney just pulled back its
racist program right
um
i longed to see
people get in the face of teachers of
principals of superintendents of schools
of school boards who are indoctrinating
their children and hate america garbage
and you know
we're so backward i was watching fox
and they're talking about the 1619
project
and they're talking about the 20 slaves
they weren't slaves i mean i've read
nell painter who is a black leftist
princeton historian on this subject
there were indentured servants
and slavery was actually outlawed in
virginia in 1619
and virginia was in america in 1619
it was a british colony
and this is supposed to be our founding
according to these liars
and yet
you know if you look at fox they're not
saying
they don't know the facts right to be
clear we were not a nation until about
150 years later so the idea that the
nation was founded on something that
happened 150 years before when everyone
was dead
uh seemed a little odd exactly it's just
terrible so so so what does the future
is people i want to see a sit-in at the
headquarters of twitter that don't see
their censorship embarrassing them
that's what's really needed and i i see
the the stirrings of it all over the
place there are people organized
particularly in the schools and that
that gives me hope
yeah do you think though that since you
brought up twitter that the big tech
part of this
is the part that makes the asymmetry so
out of whack it would be one thing if it
was slightly out of whack but now the
way we get information is so tilted that
people can't coordinate properly or
can't even get the information properly
or agree on what's true
change is coming
the one thing about tech is it's always
changing
um
[Music]
and what's called sub stack already is a
media outlet it has a lot of people who
are
second orders like you
um on it
uh people with impeccable leftist
credentials who are really upset about
the canceled cults and just the terms we
use cancel culture it's book burning
it's what the nazis did in the 30s you
can't burn just burn books today because
you got a digital universe that you
can't
but that's what it is i would like to
see people i mean i know that i'm not
making myself popular by referring to
the bind administration as fascist
but technically that's what it is
and i tell you if we don't stop them
they will put us in re-education camps
they've already telegraphed that that
conservatives are yahoo racists who have
to be reprogrammed you think do we get
to share a gulag as the y i left the
left guys that would be nice
that's very probable right very probable
great right look by sulza niedson's
gulag
archipelago uh
and that book really moved me at the
time yeah well you know i toured with
jordan peterson and he often brought up
the gulag archipelago for the same
reason i
always
thank my lucky stars for jordan peterson
otherwise i'd be feeling guilty about
all the things i wasn't writing
um so
i would like to mention is is the
chapter on chapters on the blacklist
it's very very serious i'm not going to
name the outlet but i i wrote this
article
um about how juan radar should
join the fascist and slip the knife
between my ribs i've i've got i've got
the piece right here yeah okay i play
i tried to place it
with a concer a very prominent
conservative
media site but they they're also on
facebook
you know if you're a big media site you
got to be on all the platforms
and they said that it would
facebook would shut
we'll just close it down if it appeared
there
people have to understand we are in the
early stages of a fascist state we do
not america is no longer a free country
uh its freedom is hard won by courageous
people like yourself who are willing to
stand up and take the
slings and arrows
so what do we do then i mean okay so we
can sit in a twitter i mean i know
you're you're a fighter you've been
doing this for a long time i mean what
what do we really do like where so is
trump the only thing that can save us do
we need the return of trump to lead the
republicans like it ain't gonna be liz
cheney here's what i think about trump i
you know people are talking about ron
desantis who might
admire and in my blacklist story i tell
how they used
first
you know they called me a notorious
racist then because he spoke at my
events they
use that
and when i say day i'm talking about the
so-called liberal media new magazine
washington post use that to try to
taint him
and and destroy him
and he has a delivery which a lot of
people think is
you know
more user-friendly shall we say than
trump's
um
and i hope he's on the ticket actually
but the reason
that i believe that trump
is bound to be the leader
is
[Laughter]
he got 75
million votes despite four years of
unbelievable slander and lies directed
him and no credit from what what he had
done
but i think ordinary americans patriotic
americans see this guy
and someone here he was a billionaire
living the life
and he put himself and his family
through all this
to save the country basically
and i mean those credentials are
golden you you really can't beat them
and i think his aggression is necessary
the reason the democrats hate him is
because he called them out and you know
call them out as racist for their
control of the inner cities
um
called about for their betrayal and you
know i will say as somebody who's been
in politics
50 60 years
i had no idea that they were selling us
out in trade deals the way they
i mean it's it's bush
uh it's uh
you know bush clinton
um obama either they were too lazy to
cut decent deals for americans or they
just didn't care about fleecing our
country
for chinese communists their genocidal
dictators for crying out tears if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell